うーんターンうんたんこんにちははじめさそうです
今日はですねん
こちらの
ん
10曲焼きプリンを紹介しようと思います
えっどうですあと卵入ってますねー
がちゅアレルギーの人が気を付けて下さいはいどうやら究極ですよ究極
アジアにこれはですねあのどこで買ったか忘れました
値段も忘れましたまあ注意くっていうぐらいですから
うっうん混ぜた
美味しいんだと思います
ん
ガー期待ができる
お前ら究極姉に吸ってるか英語でアルティメットって言うのよな
もうで多分ねこれがね焼きプリンなのかなあそうってんなんですよ
それはおはようさんってその大手メーカーが脱線ってとこからもう
じゃ武器ガチなんですよ田本な何に300人がない動画で小旅行つくったんでしょ
いただきますフェイス
ビッ
この度は私
初めて長がう
ちょっと謝らなければいけないことが
あります
ゲーム実況の動画をまあ part 1 part 2と出させていただいたのですが
妻年度昼ですね
すいませんが
止めませんよ読めないんですけど
サブチャンネルでばさせていただきます申し訳ないです
正座ができないので失礼します別に何すかねある
やっぱり
やっぱりこうわかんないです動画だしてたらわかるんですよ皆さんと求めているものが
メインチャンネルにゲームは求められていないってことはわかるんですよ
なんかねえ
面白いって
をもすごいって言ってくれる人は面白いと言ってくれるんですけど
僕のメインチャンネルってどうかがそんな中ってないじゃないですか
なんで来ないね
そんな
8分とかの動画版で出されても
僕のメインチャンネルではそういうのを求められてないんだなって思いました
あまりにこうジャンルが違いすぎたというか
こともあって
サブチャンネル肇社長2の方で出させて頂きます
でねやっぱり頻度もこんなたくさん
弁じゃないでたくさんゲーム実況動画だしても
なにこれってなるしパッソルチャンネルでもう頻度を気にせずねー
好き勝手
ゲーム実況動画を出させていこうと思いますよねじゃあやすくなるんですけど
まさにの昼 part 1 part 2はメインチャンネルでノーコスておくんで
part 3からは
あのはじめ冊を2で出します
すみません
本当になんか中途半端な感じになっちゃっていやでもはせますけどね再現のいるはやり
ますよ
楽しいんですよこの
も単に僕が楽しんでるだけのゲームの動画なんですけどサブチャンネルから
ご覧ください
dan
dea